we're told that a ball attached to a
string swings in a horizontal circle at
constant speed as shown below the string
makes an angle theta with the horizontal
which arrows show all the forces on the
ball so pause this video and see if you
can figure that out
okay so let's work through this together
so this ball is attached to the string
and it's clearly hanging down and I
think it's fish it's fair to say that we
are on some type of a planet and so if
we're on some type of a planet you're
definitely gonna have the force of
gravity acting on the ball so let me
draw that vector so the force of gravity
I'll do an orange let's say it looks
something like that
it's a magnitude I'll denote as capital
F with a sub G right over here now
what's keeping that ball from
accelerating downwards and also what's
keeping that ball in this uniform
circular motion and the answer to both
of those questions is the tension in the
rope remember tension is a pulling force
the Rope is pulling on this ball and so
we could say the force of the tension so
it might look something like this
the force force of the tension now just
with that we have constructed a Freebody
diagram and we can immediately answer
their question what are the forces that
are acting on the ball which arrows show
it so there's one downward and then
there's one going in the direction of
the string and if you look at these
choices here you would say it is that
one right over there now some of you
might be saying wait hold on a second
isn't there some type of a centripetal
force that keeps the ball going in a
circle that keeps it from just going
straight away straight off and then
isn't there some type of force that
counteracts the actual force of gravity
and the answer the question is yes there
is but those are really just components
of the tension and so if you look at the
X component of the tension I'll do that
in a blue
color right over here this X component
of the tension so I'll call that F sub T
X that is our centripetal force or
that's magnitude of the X component of
tension is the same thing as the
magnitude of our centripetal force and
if we look at if we look at the y
component of our attention the y
component of our tension
that's what counteracts the force of
gravity so this right over here it's
magnitude is F sub T y and F sub T Y
this magnitude is going to be the same
thing as the magnitude of the force of
gravity but we already answered our
question and we just got a little bit
more intuition of what's going on right
over here